three weeks of war
of shelling of cities besieged
and more shocking reports of attacks
which have confirmed could amount to war
crimes
10 people queueing for bread in cherniv
north of the capital kiev killed in an
alleged russian attack
in the southern city of mikolayev the
cost of conflict counted in corpses
the brutality of this war is moving
faster than peace talks
a father waits to collect the body of
his 37 year old son who leaves behind
two children of his own we said
he was so friendly he had a lot of
friends and got on well with everyone if
someone needed help he never refused and
he always worked at full capacity
foreign minister sergey lavrov says
russia is open to peace but it seems
we'll keep waging war to achieve it
our mission aims to defend the people in
donbass region from the regime and kiev
it aims to demilitarize and denazify the
region
so all ethnic groups in ukraine can live
in peace
ukrainian defenses have slowed the pace
of the russian advance
but battle lines continue to move to new
areas
the head of the regional administration
says civilian targets in zaparija were
hit overnight
the war following the path of more than
3 000 evacuees who fled there from the
besieged city of mariopol
russian troops reportedly using heavy
artillery on a civilian convoy on that
route wounding five including a child in
serious condition
russian ceasefire violations ukraine's
deputy prime minister says are stopping
civilians from using humanitarian
corridors and getting to safety
yesterday they captured the emergency
hospital and took 400 people hostage
medics in mariopol they are shooting
from inside the hospital it is a threat
for movement of people down humanitarian
corridors we've sent a request to the
red cross under these conditions we
cannot bring people out safely
ukrainian drone strikes continue to
exact a heavy price on russian forces
more russian hardware lies abandoned
following fierce fighting in
neighborhoods around kiev
the capital observing a 35-hour curfew
to prepare for an expected russian
assault
today is a special and dangerous moment
movement through the city is prohibited
without special passes you can only go
out to reach a shelter the curfew will
apply until 7 am on march 17th therefore
i ask all kiev residents to prepare for
the fact that they will have to be at
home for two days or in case of an alarm
in a shelter
diplomacy remains the only way to end
this war says ukraine's leader
it is important it is difficult but
important because any war ends in an
agreement meetings continue as i am told
the positions in the negotiations sound
more realistic however there still needs
to be more time for decisions to be in
ukraine's interests
the west of the country has avoided the
worst of the violence but the largest
single missile attack so far happened at
a military training camp in yavariv only
about an hour's drive away from here
residents say that unless there is a
ceasefire it's not a matter of if but
when the fighting makes its way here
zain basravi al-jazeera level